-President Trump vowed
to do everything in his power
to fight the opioid epidemic
which takes the lives
of 174 people each day
ravaging communities
and ripping families apart.
So what has Trump actually done
to tackle this issue,
and who's he putting in charge
of this enormously
important task?
It's time for "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-America has about
4% of the world's population
but about 27% of the world's
drug overdose deaths.
For now, opioid addiction
is one of those uniquely
American problems
like type 2 diabetes
and adults wearing shirts
with Disney characters on them.
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, we're going to
a fancy dinner."
"That's why I'm wearing
my Scrooge McDuck."
[ Laughter ]
Though among other promises
to fight the opioid epidemic,
Trump said he would increase
funding to give resources
to states that needed it most
right away.
So how did that go?
-Is the federal government
doing all it can to combat
America's opioid epidemic?
A former commissioner
of the Food and Drug
Administration says no.
-We have heard a lot of talk
from the administration on this,
but we've yet to see
the President take the kind
of serious action that
this emergency demands.
-It just is a pitiful,
pitiful story when
it comes to the amount
of real federal effort
and leadership
on the part of the President.
-Wow! And he's saying that
on Fox News.
That's what Trump watches
to feel good about himself.
That's like if the kid
tuned into "Mr. Rogers"
and Mr. Rogers said,
"News flash, snot nose.
I don't want to be
your neighbor.
[ Laughter ]
How about that?"
So the man speaking so bluntly
about Trump's inaction
is former Democratic lawmaker
Patrick Kennedy,
who also happens to be
on Trump's opioid commission
and has called it a sham
and charade saying,
"This and the administration's
other efforts to address
the epidemic are tantamount
to reshuffling chairs
on the Titanic."
But, of course,
this isn't the Titanic.
If it were, Trump would have
already tried to Billy Zane
his way on to a lifeboat.
-I have a child!
I have a child!
-Clear a path here!
-Please, I have a child.
-[ As Trump ]
"His name is Eric."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Eric ]
"Father, I'm 34!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, one of the few concrete
plans Trump did announce
to confront this issue was
that the federal government
would start a massive
advertising campaign
to get people,
especially children,
not to want to take drugs
in the first place.
Ugh, we already tried this,
and it didn't work.
But of course that's not
stopping Trump from trying.
-There is nothing desirable
about drugs.
They're bad.
[ Laughter ]
-The problem -- the problem, of
course, is that there is
something desirable about drugs.
They make you feel great.
That's why we have a huge
problem with drug addiction
and no problem at all
with celery addiction.
[ Laughter ]
You never hear anyone say,
"Yo, man, you got a stalk?"
[ Laughter ]
And for years, doctors and
pharmaceutical companies
pushed opioids for everything
from root canals
to a twisted ankle,
and everybody said, "Cool,"
because the drugs
made them feel great.
So we'll ask you again,
Mr. President,
how do you prevent addiction?
-Maybe by talking to youth
and telling them no good,
really bad for you in every way.
-Do you think anti-drug ads
work on Americans?
These are the same people
who saw a commercial
for Tide Pods and thought,
"I want to eat that."
[ Laughter ]
I'll put it in my mouth.
But I'm sure to lead
this important effort,
Trump chose someone
with experience
and impeccable credentials
in the field.
So let me just take
a big sip of water
and find out who it is.
-Kellyanne Conway will lead
the White House's effort
to combat the opioid problem
across the country.
-Were you expecting
a split take?
Because that part of me --
that part of me died months ago.
[ Laughter ]
Reports say Kellyanne
isn't even heeding the advice
of actual policy experts
of those most affected
by the this tragedy.
Now, before Kellyanne and Trump,
tackling this issue
had largely been the role
of the Office of National
Drug Control Policy.
Under the previous
administration,
the small office was made up
of public health experts
and law enforcement
who had first-hand experience
dealing with this issue,
and here's what it's been like
under Trump.
-The Office of National
Drug Control Policy,
the entity charged
with coordinating
the federal government's
counter-drug response
still does not have
a permanent director.
-The President is expected
to slash the budget
out of the Office of National
Drug Control Policy.
-Guess what --
This administration,
which talks a big game
about opioids
just proposed cutting
the agency's budget by 95%.
-That's right. Last year,
the White House allocated
about $368 million
for the office,
and for next year's budget,
they're only asking for
about $17 million.
The office trying to stop
the opioid epidemic
is getting less than
Mark Wahlberg got
for "Daddy's Home 2."
[ Laughter ]
And just hearing that news,
six more people
started taking opioids.
[ Laughter ]
But perhaps we should have
seen this coming.
The former Deputy Chief of Staff
at ONDCP was Taylor Weyeneth
who was only 24 years old.
But it's not just him.
According to Politico,
among the people working
on the public education campaign
that Trump promised
is Andrew Giuliani,
Rudy Giuliani's 32-year-old son
who's a White House
public liaison
and has no background
in drug policy.
Well, at least he's 32.
Which, if you're doing the math,
means Giuliani had him
when he was 105.
[ Laughter ]
Now Trump's budget proposals
did ask for additional funding
to fight the opioid epidemic,
and the Justice Department
recently announced
that it would go after opioid
manufacturers and distributors.
Those are positive steps.
But at the same time, Trump
is trying also trying to repeal
the Affordable Care Act
and slash Medicaid programs
that already help people
who are addicted.
And that is, um -- What's
the phrase I'm looking for?
-No good. Really bad.
-This has been "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]